[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists ryan we often buy
things that look great in an instagram
ad
just to receive a package filled with
silly second-rate sub-standard stuff
have you ever purchased something that
looked great online but it turned out to
be
a piece of junk
are you talking about wish.com
well maybe that thing you purchased fell
apart after a month maybe it didn't live
up to all the reviews maybe it was cheap
flimsy and inferior today on this public
episode of the minimalist podcast we're
talking about
the good goods
that is high quality things that last
useful things that we are grateful to
own then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
talk about seven brands we trust for
home furnishings and other household
goods we'll also talk to some of our
listeners
about some of the mediocre things
they've purchased that didn't match the
hype you can check that out at
patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
all right ryan before we get into our
questions today yeah i want to talk
about this title yes where the good good
comes from or the good goods yeah i wish
i wish i could say that we thought of it
i know because it's so good it is so
good it's that good good we're not
talking about morally good by the way
right we're talking about
well things that we enjoy right oh
that's good yeah yeah and our friend
brett and janelle both of our friends
they run a great coffee shop in dayton
ohio this started the month after we
started the minimalist so we started
in december of 2010 they opened this
coffee shop called press
in dayton ohio they now have two
locations and they roast their own
coffee under the name wood burl coffee
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes we don't get anything from telling
you about them but their
slogan for many years now their tagline
for their coffee is that good good yeah
and it is they do a really good job it's
crazy to me how
you know you and i uh when we were in
the corporate world trying to find a way
out of it we talked about opening up a
coffee shop
and we listed out a bunch of names and
press
was one of the names that we came up
with that's right that's really wild
yeah and uh well they are good friends
of ours in fact our first three books
minimalism everything that remains and
essential were all
partially written in that coffee shop in
dayton in fact you could you see that
coffee shop now in our last film on
netflix yes is now
and
uh all three of those first three books
were edited completely in
that coffee shop
there on wayne avenue in dayton ohio so
shout out to them but today we're not
talking about coffee although we can
they make great coffee but we're talking
about good goods the good goods the
things that we enjoy useful things that
we are grateful to own before we dive
into the questions
i have a survey question for you where
do you listen to this podcast do me a
favor hop on youtube and let me know
because i'm just curious about this for
something i'm working on in the future
where do you listen to this podcast are
you at the gym are you washing dishes
are you cleaning the house are you at
work are you in the car
are you on a stakeout
[Laughter]
every time i see a stakeout in a
movie i look at back so i'm like we
should do stakeouts
it looks so fun looks fun you can sit
there listen to audiobook or listen to
podcasts you get binoculars binoculars
cool gadgets
oh man speaking of cool gadgets that's
what i always um i haven't like went out
and bought any cool gadgets but i always
see cool gadget um advertisements on
instagram right it'll be like a floating
lamp or like you know what i'm talking
about absolutely yeah
what almost got me was that light phone
because i was like oh man like that's be
so good to have that like just regular
basic phone no texting but then i
realized i would just basically have to
carry around a laptop then to do certain
things yeah i can just do it anyway i
thought about that as well with the
light phone like this is great and then
i started thinking more like i know i
hate phone calls this does the one thing
that i hate doing exactly yeah back in
our corporate days we were in telecom
and i remember we'd get our bills and
they were free but like it would show me
how many minutes i was using a month and
there were some months where i was using
7
000 minutes a month that's insane yeah
yeah and so anyway let's move on to the
good goods we have some questions here
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or comment for our podcast
give us a call 406
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
our first question today is from leanne
in riverside ohio which is really just
dayton ohio yeah is there a curated list
somewhere on the internet of companies
that sell high quality durable goods
that also take responsibility for their
social and environmental impact so
leanne i think this is an expansive
question i'm glad we're starting the
episode with this question by the way
shout out to our patrons who are
watching this live right now
if you have a question or comment for us
as you're watching this live leave it in
the chat we'll do our best to get to
those as soon as we can or we'll get to
them on the maximal episode this week as
well so leanne let's talk about a few
things you're asking about
socially conscious companies responsible
companies who are responsible for their
social and environmental impact so i
want to talk about a few things with you
ryan because i think we need to get some
terms out on the table but then i have
some lists of some actual companies
we'll put links to these in the show
notes but let's start by talking about
what a b corporation is i'm sure it's a
term that many people are becoming
familiar with now because a b
corporation doesn't just put money first
and so i have this wikipedia article
here so also known as a benefit
corporation although there can be
distinctions between a b corp and a
benefit corporation i'm not going to get
into the exact details here but i'm just
going to read this for you and we can
use it as a jump off point for
discussion here in business
b corporation also b lab or b corp is a
private certification
of for-profit companies of their social
and environmental performance it is
distinct from the legal designation as a
benefit corporation b corp certification
is conferred by be lab a global
nonprofit organization with offices in
the united states europe canada
australia and new zealand and a
partnership in latin america to be
granted and to maintain certification
companies must receive a minimum score
of 80 from an assessment of quote social
and environmental performance integrate
b corp commitments to stakeholders into
the company governing documents and pay
an annual fee based on annual sale sales
companies must re-certify every three
years to maintain their status
so here's the purpose of a b corp b lab
certification is a third party standard
requiring companies to meet social
sustainability
environmental performance standards meet
accountability standards and be
transparent to the public according to
the score they receive on the assessment
b lab certification applies to the whole
company across all product lines and
issue areas let me talk to you real
quick about how this is different from a
regular corporation okay now quite often
it's easy to demonize corporations right
yeah and because a corporation is sounds
evil you you even it conjures these
images of like there's this old stuffy
guy who's in the ivory tower making
decisions to kill people and hurt the
environment and you know what that is
that's not far off in some corporations
yeah
and and so
the problem is when we talk about
corporations it's a lot different every
non-profit that you know of is a
non-profit corporation right so when we
demon when we demonize corporations
we're inadvertently also demonizing
non-profit corporations
the difference is there's non-profit
there's for-profit and there's these
sort of in-between areas you have b
corporations there's a grocery store
right down the street erwin that is a b
corporation oh and so what this means is
a regular traditional s corp
or any other sort of court regular
corporation for-profit corporation tends
to have a fiduciary responsibility in
which
their main objective
is to make money
above all else a b corp money it does
play a role in fact it has to play a
role otherwise you're going to go out of
business you can't do the social good
that you want to do
but it is not the only thing that is
driving the vehicle there are social and
environmental aspects of a b corporation
now there are some other designations
i'm going to run by you real quick we're
not going to dive into the details of
them because
well
it starts to get a little bit confusing
because
they're just some subtle nuances between
the other three that i wanted to mention
low profit llcs also known as
l3cs
they're a form of business entity in the
united states commonly referred to as a
hybrid structure
so um this is a irs designation
and so again profitability not being the
main main thing but they also are a
social enterprise
and then we have what is called a social
purpose corporation very similar a
social purpose corporation or spc is a
type of for-profit entity a corporation
in some u.s states that enables but did
not but does not require considering
social and environmental issues in
decision making so enables meaning like
okay you don't have to put money first
here right yeah and i'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well and then
finally we have what is called a
sustainable business a sustainable
business or a green business is an
enterprise that has minimal negative
impact or potentially positive effect on
the global or local environment
community society or economy a business
that strives to meet the triple bottom
line
and it goes on to talk about what the
triple bottom line is i also want to
talk to you on the maximal this week
ryan about green washing oh yeah it's
this uh this um this term where quite
often these companies that try to appear
sustainable
but they're simply green washing their
their business
in a way greenwashing well we'll get
into that on the maximal this week but
to get back to the question at hand from
leanne leanne when we're talking about
socially responsible companies quite
often they fall under one of these
monikers right they're either b corp
they're a low profit llc
or they are a social purpose company
they're a sustainable business and so i
pulled up some lists ryan that i wanted
to talk to you about this first list is
from grow ensemble we'll put a link to
this in the show notes and it's 10 of
our favorite socially responsible
companies this is great man this uh the
b corp this is like total news to me i
had no idea that there was there was a
designation like that for corporations
the reason you probably didn't have an
idea is there aren't many of them it's
pretty stringent it's difficult to
become a b corp it's relatively new
within the last decade or so okay but as
of q2
2022
there are only about what is it 4 800
b corps
in 153 industries in 79 countries so
there's probably a few thousand in the
united states so yeah because the rest
the the
it takes a lot to become a b corp a
socially conscious corp however
it doesn't mean that you can't do
something socially conscious without
that status right right yeah you and i
we have a regular llc yeah we don't have
a what is it a low profit limited like i
mean although some years it's certainly
low profit
i might even call it a low profit but
just doesn't have that irs designation
right and so
that's cool uh one thing i want to talk
about when we're answering leanne's
question here once we get past some of
these socially responsible companies is
i want to talk about some other
companies who fall in there that might
be a little bit surprising so here are
10 of our favorite socially responsible
companies according to grow ensemble i
kind of want to like try and guess the
company's on this list but i won't do
that because yeah give me two give me
two guesses patagonia the first one on
the list okay all right and then um
i'll just say i'll just stick with
patagonia i don't have anything else on
the top
well here's some notable b corporations
this is from the wikipedia page entry um
all birds ben and jerry's coursera oh
etiquette
uh patagonia saxbys so so patagonia is
also a b corp seventh generation the
body shop
something called meow wolf
and obviously there are 4 800 but
patagonia is the first one on the the
list here patagonia gives one percent of
all sales to environmental organizations
globally their organization is
considered quote the activist company as
calls to action are found directly
within their website in addition to
serving as a link to action patagonia
hosts a phenomenal blog that showcases
some of the most impactful environmental
efforts in some of the most beautiful
places around the world plus patagonia
is a founding member of the fair labor
association and makes all of their
products from sustainable or recycled
materials wow we're going to be talking
about that more about finding clothing
companies that are sustainable and
environmentally friendly as well
responsible the second one on here you
certainly could have guessed dr bronners
oh of course dr bronner's yes i could
have guessed that i just bought some of
their soap uh this weekend from my local
pharmacy
and in fact bex and i just moved into
this new house and we're getting to know
this new
awesome community of like seven or eight
thousand people
and
learning of all the local businesses
we're gonna talk about that in terms of
the good goods here as well i'll mention
a few more here clean canteen spelled
with 2ks clean canteen oh yeah ella my
daughter has a clean canteen and she
thinks ryan i both have one a little
sippy cup that she uses yeah right
exactly it's a spill proof sippy cup and
that is totally works really well
because i tend to spill a lot of things
[Laughter]
but this prevents it from getting
everywhere
there's a something called all good
products which i was unfamiliar with
till i read about this all good products
is a b corporation member that sells
skin products that are good for your
family and good for the planet this
organization is especially known for
reef friendly sunscreen
and you can also learn why this is
important in the article here
another one is warby parker the glasses
manufacturer oh they're an example of
real world experience problem solving
when its founders confronted the
obstacle of overly expensive glasses
they launch into action providing an
affordable eyewear company like many
socially responsible product-based
companies warby parker supports
transparency
sharing how their glasses are made with
its customers and i think that's one
thing that comes up quite often with
many of these socially responsible
companies is there's a an additional
layer of transparency how the sausage or
the coca-cola is made is often foreign
to us it's just like i buy the product
and
i'm going to just pretend nothing
harmful went into this chemical wise any
harmful labor practices when you have a
company like warby parker who's being
more transparent then quite often we can
feel better about the things that we buy
yeah i will tell you though last week on
the added value segment of the podcast
with tk coleman i talked about a book
that just came out i think last year
called the every
and danny unknown wherever he is he's
he's um he's reading it right now and
one of the things they talk about in
there is impact anxiety
oh wow and i don't know if that's a term
that dave edgar's invented the author of
the book or it certainly feels like
something that is part of the zeitgeist
but yeah we worry about what impact is
this going to make
and one of the ways that we can reduce
that worry is by
supporting companies that are
environmentally friendly or responsible
it doesn't mean that we have to be 100
perfect and we're going to talk about
that in this episode how we can balance
it out by being more intentional more
frequently we've got a couple more
companies here for you ben and jerry's
which i mean might be yes they are
committed to
fair trade climate action lbgtq
equality
etc but also
um keep in mind that you're still buying
ice cream still buying frozen frozen
sugar
and i think that that's a perfect
illustration if you're going to buy ice
cream why not why not buy it from a a
company that does support or align that
does align with your values in some way
if you have those values but then also
keeping in mind that
buying more ice cream to be more
to reduce your impact
agony or impact anxiety
is not
ideal because it's going to give you a
different kind of anxiety yes and how do
we apply that to the rest of our
consumption buying more sustainable
products is not this is most sustainable
route yeah yeah you cannot buy your way
to sustainability
tweet that podcast sean wherever you are
today we got p3 sitting in for uh for
podcast john today uh bomb bus which
many of my socks are actually maybe all
of my socks are from cool bombas
they uh they do the sort of model where
you buy a pair and they give a pair to
someone in need especially like homeless
shelters and
and and
people who are
uh
who who are outside of homeless shelters
as well unhoused individuals
they
quite often the number one request sucks
yeah yeah it's so bombus provides those
it's we uh we have that one venue we go
to in chicago i forget the name of it
the wilbur no anyway italia hall yeah
yeah hall and uh they always have like
socks laying out for basically the bands
that come through and i had no idea but
sky steel we were at that venue he was
opening up for us and he was explaining
to me how like clean socks is like the
number one thing that musicians on the
road need all the time that's right yeah
so yeah it's not too surprising to find
out so they're like the toms for socks
yes in fact tom's another company that's
on here i was gonna yeah i own a pair of
toms i stopped wearing them recently
full disclosure a few weeks ago i talked
about these shoes that i have which i
don't know what list i don't see them on
this list uh they're called i don't even
know what they're called suaves is it on
the bottom yeah i own i own a few pairs
there's no logo or anything uh i own
toms but they the quality was starting
to reduce for me
because i wear them all the time and
these these are super comfortable i just
wonder how sustainable they are yeah but
one way these are more sustainable for
me is they have this insert
that i pull out and you can just replace
this insert without having to replace
the whole shoe also you can wash these
shoes in your washing machine that's
cool which i have a washing machine for
the first time in many years
with this bex and i just bought this new
house we're going to actually do a
a future podcast episode in the not too
distant future about home ownership
versus renting because i have certain
anxieties about home ownership in
general i want to share those with you
but we'll talk a bit about some of the
the new home furnishings that bex and i
are considering on the maximal episode
this week and i want to run some ideas
by ryan here's one other one
that i'm actually going to be
um
a customer of in the not too distant
future this is the grove collaborative
you've maybe heard of grove i'm not sure
they're another certified b corp
the grove is your one-stop shop for all
things healthy home and personal care
the grove collaborative provides an
option for you to purchase products that
are safer for you and your family and
its products are geared toward a
healthier planet as well the grove is a
member of the carbon offsetting movement
and as mentioned earlier for every
shipment they purchase carbon credits to
counter balance their emissions clean
delivery for happy cleaning so cleaning
products that aren't full of harsh
chemicals and unhealthy for you and your
family but also
their social and environmentally
conscious company as well
and so a couple others on here
aspiration which i had never heard of
until yesterday
aspiration is a neo bank an online
financial institution that is wait for
it a b corp certified and a one percent
for the planet member
and so uh it's a bank that is
sustainable it's like an online bank it
is yeah okay and then finally on here
they have toms we all know the sort of
one for one model you buy a pair of
shoes they give a pair of shoes to
someone in need we'll put a link to that
in the show notes i also have another
link for another article here 12
socially responsible companies to
applaud there is some overlap in that
one but there are several others in
there like lego which was surprising to
me that is yeah that's crazy the lake
the lego group achieved an a leadership
status in the 19 or in the 2021 cdp
climate change questionnaire making it
the sixth consecutive year the company
received a leadership level cdp climate
change rating that's well because
they're
little pieces of plastic exactly yeah
that's that's yeah good for them which
actually brings me to the next article
and this is why i want to be careful i
want to be a little skeptical of these
lists
because this one is from donorbox we'll
put a link to this in the show notes as
well it's 14
sustainable companies and this list
completely different from the first two
adidas starbucks
ikea
bosch wait ben and jerry's is there
again apple coca-cola alaska airlines
wow bmw dell walt disney and microsoft
yeah now this list is a list of socially
responsible companies that are strongly
committed to quote
corporate social responsibility
or crs
now here's what i want to talk to you
about ryan i also want to talk to leanne
about this
here's the problem we run into
when we look for certain prescriptions
criteria
anyone can sort of find their ways to
game the system yes and so
i i'm torn here because
yes if coca-cola is making steps to be
more environmentally conscious is that
a net positive
relative to them not doing it sure yeah
but perhaps the true net positive is not
us
supporting a business
that provides these sugary drinks that
creates a lot of dis-ease
in in our world and so the most
intentional
consumption has to do with limiting our
consumption to things that truly add
value to our lives
if the average american household has
300 000 items in it
but 90 plus percent of those things are
obsolete or useless or get in the way
clutter right
then
it's more sustainable
to focus on the 10 of the things or the
5 or whatever that we do need
and don't be
anxious about the things that we do need
the things that add value to our lives
and yes buy them from sustainable
companies we can but the most
sustainable thing
is to remove ourselves from the equation
of buying the useless junk yeah in the
first place yeah absolutely i do know
that coca-cola
they use recycled bottles
like they yeah so maybe that's why
they're on that list it could be and the
article goes into in depth in fact you
know what let's look at coca-cola real
quick as one of the examples adidas
shocked me starbucks shocked me yeah
most of those ikea ikea most of those
shocked me yeah let's see coca-cola is
right here coca-cola donates at least
one percent of its annual operating
income to supporting causes and
initiatives since 2014 they have helped
provide clean drinking water for
refugees in the middle east through
arwa's price of water campaign more
learn more about this here so okay so
they are doing some
socially conscious and environmentally
conscious things however
it could be the most environmentally
conscious thing to not buy it at all
right
you know ryan we got some questions here
from patreon alabama let's talk to rico
for a second
can anything high quality be bought from
a dollar store
anything of high quality so ryan here's
what i want to talk to you about so i
think we're maybe asking a question the
wrong question here
yeah i don't mean morally wrong i mean
the wrong question in the sense of like
can it be healthy to eat poop
the answer to that is actually yes
there's something called fmt's fecal
transplants right if you have problems
with your gut microbiome and your small
intestine or especially in your colon
your large intestine then there are ways
to reseed your gut microbiome
by either doing a suppository of feces
or swallowing feces yeah and
but most of us aren't going to say
should i eat poop today right yeah i see
what you're saying now how how why am i
why am i comparing a dollar store to
poop well here here's another thing it's
pretty clear
here's another article for you ryan it's
called five environmental and ethical
costs of shopping at dollar stores when
you buy something at a dollar store
you'll likely walk out having spent less
than you would have elsewhere
you may have saved money but you
certainly won't be saving anything else
because you're popping up uh because
you're popping up on seemingly every
corner or because they are popping up on
seemingly every corner it's not hard to
drop in for a quick cheap purchase but
unfortunately
we've come up with five
uh we've come up with five environmental
and ethical costs of shopping at dollar
stores that aren't listed on the price
tag
so what are dollar stores first off
family dollar dollar tree and dollar
general are some of the big names in the
world of dollar stores their main
business ethos is pretty easy to
understand provide customers with
convenience and affordability and i'll
even say this ryan that
these cheap goods
they benefit
both the consumer and
the
corporation at least ostensibly right
and in the very short term yes because i
can save some money on a cheap widget
that is probably going to break
very soon right now the question is that
i need that cheap widget in the first
place
and are there quality items in some of
these dollars sure i'm sure i'm sure
some things in the dollar store are of
some quality and they may last a while
yeah but the truth that we're going to
see in this article
is that there is a whole lot of other
costs outside of that that dollar yeah
and we want to be careful with how we're
spending our time and what else we're
doing to the planet here so
uh it says
that these dollar stores are taking most
of our cities by storm in fact as
america's neighborhood general store
dollar general now has more than 17 000
locations and 46
states
they are offering everything beauty and
health supplies food and snacks cleaning
supplies apparel seasonal items paper
products and housewares they offer many
of the same brands and products that
at other stores like drug stores and
grocery stores but
they do so at a cheaper price and i'll
say this an ostensibly cheaper price
right because as we'll learn here it's
not always cheaper yeah there are other
costs associated you know what's
interesting about that though like a lot
of brands start out in the dollar store
so like for example x body spray that
was a cheapo one dollar thing at the at
the dollar store and then it started to
get popular so now they're like oh now
we can charge more for this and put it
in
you know in the more expensive stores
yeah same thing with like mrs meyers
that was
a dollar store brand um soap now it's
like
and maybe we'll get into this a little
bit in the maximal but it's it's a green
washing type
uh company yeah that yeah that looks
healthy looks like it's good for you not
a lot of chemicals and yeah they they
charge you with that in mind uh yeah
they up charge you but uh yeah it's
interesting mariah has a just a
sensitivity to stuff so she's got this
app you could look up different brands
and it'll tell you on a scale of like
one to five or something about like how
how toxic it is
do you remember the name of that app
ew oh yeah ewg that's where i check my
tap water as well yeah yeah so like mrs
myers actually is um what is it like a
three or four
four out of ten
okay four yeah four and five out of ten
so again
like the green washing they make it look
super healthy but you actually look at
what's in it and
um it may not be as healthy as it is to
be yeah so here are five ways that the
here are the five environmental and
ethical costs of shopping at dollar
stores i'll say that one more time here
here are the environmental and ethical
calls five of them for shopping at
dollar stores number one dollar stores
hurt local economies
so that's a big thing that we rarely
think about you know and it's not just
dollar stores it's amazon walmart etc i
remember when ryan we were kids and
walmart came to town in 88. oh my god
and it just decimated yeah the little
sort of local downtown areas right yeah
and i remember in middletown ohio in
particular
you know you go down that whole downtown
there is now it's like one of the most
tragic areas it looks a lot like east st
louis or something yeah it's wild and
now there is a revitalization effort
going on down there
because but it was far enough away where
all these these big box stores opened up
and killed the local economy one of the
nice things about where uh bex and i
just moved up in ventura county
um i'm not going to talk about the city
just yet we're going to rev
we're going to reveal that on a future
episode uh talk about the local
community but one thing i'll tell you is
the
the
there are no big chain stores anywhere
in fact you have to drive like 30
minutes away to get to like a cvs or
walgreens but there are
what that does it forces me to support
the local caring businesses
and if i don't like one of the
pharmacies there's like two other
pharmacies right and so you get to know
the people i i met the local butcher
there recently and you know bought some
local grass-fed grass-finished beef and
liver and heart and bone marrow right
there in my neighborhood supporting the
local
economy
and one thing that we don't realize when
we go to a dollar store or a walmart or
somewhere else is we aren't supporting
people locally per se now of course
local workers potentially
but we're not supporting local business
owners and most of that money if you go
to one of these giant
multinational corporations most of that
money is not going back in to your local
community yeah number two dollar stores
are associated with negative health
incomes
even if a resident doesn't score a job
there at first glance the opening of a
dollar store in a food desert might come
across as a good thing yeah i would
agree with that in fact before we opened
the the grocery store the grocer the
non-profit grocery co-op in dayton
that's where a lot of people bought
their food interesting unfortunately
what most of that food is processed junk
yeah seed oils
and
all these preservatives
packaged foods and so it's
perpetuating this ease in the local
community yeah number three is
dollar stores arguably aren't even that
cheap while they sell
in smaller quantities that have
extremely affordable price tags for many
items particularly food items the price
per weight is comparable or even more
expensive than it might be elsewhere
washington post did an analysis found
the dollar that a bottle of
a dollar bottle of milk at a dollar
store equated to eight dollars for a
full gallon oh wow so you're actually
paying more
thank goodness i don't have to fill my
car up with uh dollar store milk
right
i don't know it's pretty dag on clothes
here in l.a yeah that's true
number four dollar stores use a lot of
packaging and a lot of toxic products
because the dollar store is able to
shrink nearly any product and turn it
into a cheap alternative that actually
is more expensive than it would be if
purchased in its full normal size they
use they use significantly more
packaging than other companies so i
think that's something to think about
when you're buying these individually
packaged things you're producing more
waste inadvertently yeah and number five
ryan
dollar stores equal
environmental injustice
this brings us to a problem our country
is facing and dollar stores like these
certainly play a role in environmental
justice issues the individuals who see
the bright yellow dg sign down the
street and who rely on it for many of
their essentials are likely choosing
between food and rent and struggling to
meet their basic needs right i think
that's um
i think that's true when you see a lot
of these dollar shows they're popping up
in neighborhoods without grocery stores
right
and quite often they are preying on
low-income people and so
while the prices appear to be cheaper
it's just like if i were to sell you
cigarettes individually ryan it's going
to appear to be cheaper i'm doing two
things here i'm actually charging you
more
as opposed to buying a whole pack of
cigarettes yeah but at the same time i'm
also selling you cigarettes right which
are harmful to those communities in
particular right yeah i mean the
communities where you and i grew up were
really poor and we didn't have access to
a local grocery store real close to
where we were
and yet we had access to an equivalent
of a dollar store right yeah a sort of
convenience store with cheetos and
liquor and a lot of things that are
unhealthy for us
without the alternatives to the
unhealthy things yeah
yeah man it's it's such a hard because
like i feel like i need to throw the
caveat in here like this isn't trying to
make anyone feel bad for shopping at the
dollar store or like any judgment but it
is what it is and it's
it's an important thing to note that
like yeah some of these folks shopping
they have to choose between rent and
other and food and um
man i i would dare say like some of
there's a certain percentage of people
that maybe that dollar store is
the only option they have with their the
income that they have that's right yeah
but i would also i would also add on to
that understanding like when you and i
were growing up we didn't have much
money we that very little bit of money
that we did have
we misspent it quite often on things we
didn't need absolutely now food we
obviously need and the question is do i
have access to healthy food and can i do
it in a budget friendly way and the
answer to that is certainly yes we have
to be intentional about that we did a
podcast on that didn't we we did yeah
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes
but i do want to move on to a question
we have here from effie on facebook
how has planned obsolescence changed the
way we shop
let's talk about what planned
obsolescence is i think drives me crazy
well i think quite often we we think
that there is this
secret cabal of like tech overlords who
are intentionally
trying to get us to upgrade their phone
every year by
making their phones or gadgets
self-destructible
right and i will say there's actually i
found in doing the research for this i
actually found two industries in which
that tends to be true yeah and it's not
like there's there's the truth lies
somewhere between there is no planned
obsolescence obsolescence and these
overlords like there's somewhere in the
middle where
it's it is true to an extent and let me
give you two examples of two industries
where it's closer to the overlords who
these cartels of manufacturers who are
actually intentionally making products
that expire before they should expire
the first one light bulbs
and so the light bulb industry and it
has changed significantly in fact if you
just go to google type in light bulbs
planned obsolescence
you will see that light bulbs used to
last appreciably longer than they do now
and talk about an environmental impact
of constantly changing all of these
light bulbs but the other one that i
think is most pronounced and it drives
all of us mad
printer ink cartridges oh my goodness
man
you can get a you can get a printer for
like 10 bucks but then like the ink is a
million dollars
everyone in the studio right now is like
yes
and here's the thing in fact they've
even been caught
while they put sensors on the printers
that tell you the printer is out of ink
even though it still has half a
cartridge left or whatever wow so it
stops the printing for you on your
behalf and talk about a ton of waste
yeah and there are other times we have
to replace like well i'm out of red so
now i have to also replace the green and
the blue
you know i don't we don't have a color
printer but
keeping that in mind there is planned
obsolescence here but i have yeah an
article here ryan this is from sierra
it's the magazine from the sierra club
and this article which we'll put a link
to in the show notes is called
built not to last
how to overcome planned obsolescence
in 2020 people worldwide bought some 24
million pairs of shoes 64 million cars
and 1.4 billion smartphones
200 million of them from apple
wow more than 80 of iphones sold last
year went to quote upgraders not first
time buyers it's all part of business as
usual since the 1920s when light bulb
manufacturers teamed up purposefully to
purposely limit the lifespans of their
products that becomes a cartel right
yeah companies have been locked into a
business model rooted in the concept of
planned obsolescence to quote grow
at least the way economists defined it
corporations have to sell us
more stuff every year
which is why there are ever changing
products made from low quality
or even toxic material materials by
people working
in unjust conditions
planned obsolescence is why we see
software mysteriously slow down
furniture designed with hollow legs and
cheap staples and clothing burned
because it can't sell fast enough we're
gonna talk about fast fashion on the
maximal episode this week ryan yeah
that's yeah that's unfortunate do they
uh
talk about like refrigerators and things
like that in this article as well is
your refrigerator running
[Laughter]
i better go catch it
but no i know that like um
i don't know i saw some tick tock video
over like a guy was showing his
refrigerator from the 50s that like
still works
and then he shows like a modern
refrigerator that doesn't last more than
five years listen what isn't that wild
yeah that's crazy well it goes on to say
as
repair shops close landfills expand
how did we get here how can we change
course and that's what i want to talk
about
with this respect to this question from
effie today ryan is we know how we got
here at this point we
we're partially to blame for the oh yeah
planned obsolescence and in fact that's
the only part that we can control really
yeah
last week we talked to tk about
controlling the controllables and
marking off all of the things that you
know
we talked about creating a list of
everything you worry about write down on
a sheet of paper write down everything
you are worried about and then cross off
the things that you can't control focus
on the things you can control yeah and
what can we control with planned
obsolescence here
we can control what we buy yeah because
if we're demanding cheap products
constantly more and more and more
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper then yes
they're going to be obsolete that might
benefit us in the short term but it
benefits corporations in the short and
long term because they're able to
exploit workers overseas they're able to
use cheap or even toxic materials in
their products that are yet to be
regulated and so
this article goes on to talk about the
components of planned obsolescence i'm
going to go through these components
with you individually real quick ryan so
we have design
linear growth
low wages product logistics marketing
disconnection so a moment ago
that we were talking about
buying locally right well local people
there's no planned obsolescence sort of
built into that you develop a
relationship with a local business over
time a bike shop is usually also the
bike repair shop as well
and so
they're not going to make or sell you a
bike that is going to break down on day
one because they want your repeat
business for years and years to come if
you lose their trust on the initial sale
then you've they've lost your business
in perpetuity right a little bit
different with the dollar store they're
not fixing anything for you right yeah
here's a history of planned obsolescence
1924
an international group of light bulb
manufacturers called the phoebus cartel
agrees to limit the lifespan of bulbs to
around 100 1 000 hours significantly
shorter than the previous standard
there's a legit cartel who decided this
yes in 1924 so 100 years ago is really
when planned obsolescence started even
the term didn't come into vogue until i
think the 1950s
1927 general motors had alfred p sloan
introduces quote dynamic obsolescence
to maintain sales
as automobile markets began to reach a
saturation point gm unveils the
industry's first design studio to foster
demand for updated car styles and colors
and this is
particularly insidious because you know
you can take your toyota corolla that
you had ryan and all of a sudden now you
see the new version of toyota corolla
come out yeah and it's like oh that one
looks better than mine
they made some
slight tweaks and adjustments and the
spoiler sure does look great
whatever you're into
i mean if you don't have a spoiler on
your car are you really living
[Laughter]
1929 christine federick publishes
selling mrs customer which champions
quote
progressive progressive
obsolescence a plan to stoke consumption
by tapping people's love of changing
fashions ma'am quote the same thrill
that women have
always had over new clothes women are
now also obtaining over replacement
changes reconstruction new colors and
forms and all types of merchandise
so that fast fashion yeah the fashion
trends now everything
is trendy from our cookware to our
utensils to our couches
to our landscaping it constantly needs
to be upgraded replaced updated changed
improved bettered
and it's making us freaking miserable
it's crazy we do have this fixation
though for like constantly upgrading
things that's right i mean every time
the new iphone comes out i'm like oh i
don't know what it does but it sure does
look a little prettier than the one i
have right now
and in fact now it's so
it's so it's such a part of the
marketing mm-hmm that if you show me if
you were to set down an iphone 12 and an
iphone 13 yeah i don't think i would
know the difference yeah at first glance
yeah they're pretty uh pretty similar
but they make us feel as though we're
behind yeah they do with how do they how
do you do that and this is why we always
say advertisements suck
they do it through advertising making
you feel inadequate because you don't
have the most up-to-date product yeah
and they do with the unboxing experience
too like there is a weird satisfaction
of like everything fits perfect in that
little box
and like even the yeah the experience of
unwrapping it like gives you a little
bit of a dopamine head that's right yeah
and so
part of that is really nice creating a
positive experience like i don't want my
purchases to be a negative experience
but i also don't want it to be you a
euphoric experience because then what do
i do i go back and i
need the dopamine dopamine i need one
more hit of consumerism
you know i'll put a link to this article
in the show notes there's one other bit
i'm going to skip forward there was 1932
1954. 1989 new york times coins the term
fast fashion upon opening of the
flagship zara store in new york 1996
ikea launches the chuck out your chins
campaign
which encourages british women to
dispose of their stodgy old furniture
embrace the quote freedom
of regularly replacing living room sets
wow the freedom of replacing your
furniture every three years sounds so
free you know what's interesting ryan i
when we talked to the minimalist
architect on our first film frank
he talked about when he bought the couch
the reason he spent two or three years
he ended up designing his own couch
was because he wanted to make that
decision for the rest of his life this
was his rest of the life couch and bex
and i the home we just we purchased
we're considering
slowly very slowly populating the space
with okay what's the couch we want for
the rest of our lives yeah what's the
bed that we want for the rest of our
lives what's the mattress that we want
for the next 20 years
and asking these questions it's a
sustainable question now it doesn't make
it a euphoric consumer process it's
driving me insane and i'll talk to you
about why it's driving me so crazy
partially because i'm a completionist
but
i don't want to be replacing the living
room set every three years five years
right i don't need to be trendy what is
timeless meaning what's going to last my
lifetime yeah and finally in 2001
apple's newly introduced ipod
has an unreplaceable battery that lasts
only 18 months sparking outrage yeah so
that's planned obsolescence we're gonna
check in with our live stream during the
maximal episode this week for the sake
of time ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments to
four yes indeed 937-202-4654 the
lightning round so ryan and i do our
best to answer your questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media oh by the way you can find
all of our minimal maxims now in one
place minimal
maxims.com we have a question here from
dina
i've found that more expensive doesn't
always equal better quality how do we
look for something that's good quality
and reasonably priced oh where's my
pithy answer for you i can find i have
two for you
everything is 100 off if you don't buy
it
let me expand on that real quick so i
don't
i don't buy things i don't wait for
something to go on sale to buy it
in fact when i see something on sale i
tend to avoid it yeah to me sale is a
you know i think now because i used to
think oh it'd be dumb not to buy it
right what do i do every time i walk by
joseph a bank ryan
you joke around about how you'd be dumb
not to go in there and spend a bunch of
money yeah because there's always a sale
i'll take a picture in front of it they
have a perpetual sale yes and it's like
50 off buy one tie get seven for free
remember when i was like looking at
buying shirts in like a suit and stuff
and i called you up i'm like dude joseph
bakes is having a really crazy sale
should i do it and you're like dude they
always have a sale
yeah you're at the town and country mall
in dayton ohio yeah and um it's in
kettering yeah and i remember that you
sent me that picture and i'm like ryan
it's it's i'll send you a picture
you're it's like buy one shirt get for
free right yeah you're like well no
you're actually not i don't need five
shirts maybe right maybe dumb not to do
it right but of course
maybe i'd be dumb to do it
whenever i see sale price before it was
oh wait i must act now
sense of urgency i'm going to miss out
yeah but now it's the joy of missing out
the piece of missing out when i see
something on sale now you know what i
think oh what's wrong with that item
yeah why did they produce something why
don't people want it yeah if the sale
triggers
me to want to buy it that's usually a
sign that i probably don't need that
thing right now if i go to the grocery
store and i'm like oh the rice is 30 off
today great yeah you're not like
spitefully not buying no i'm gonna wait
until this is regular price exactly but
i do not seek out sale price because i
seek to buy very few things because i
want my goods to be the good goods
regardless of what their price is and
yes i will spend a little bit more on a
item that i feel aligns with my values
but i can do that because i'm buying 1
100th of what i used to buy yes and so
i'm not going into debt to buy a bunch
of things that i don't need yeah and
keep in mind too like uh like the the
black friday electronic sales they
intentionally will make these cheaper
versions of a product specifically
uh specifically so they can charge you
know half the price um but you're
getting an inferior inferior product
that's right yeah
i have one more pithy answer for you
ryan what do you got the most
sustainable item
is the item that's left on the shelf um
amen and so quite often we're trying to
decide between two toxic things which is
the lesser of two evils or whatever not
realizing you have a third option yeah
and that third option is to not buy the
thing unless you're absolutely certain
you need it you're absolutely certain it
will add value to your life now of
course i'm not saying deprive yourself
but it might make it make sense to
temporarily deprive yourself of
something you think you need because
maybe you can go without it for a day
one of the rules that we have in the
free minimalist rule book that you can
download the minimalists.com rule book
is called the 30 30 rule or the wait for
it rule if something costs more than
thirty dollars i might have to update
this with inflation but
if something goes more than thirty two
dollars
oh gosh that's uh sixty dollars now yeah
no if it's if it's more than thirty
dollars i wait thirty hours so basically
what does that mean any significant
purchase i wait a day or so
because if i'm waiting a day it turns
out and i'll i'll simply if i'm going to
put it in my online shopping cart i'll
do that or i'll just put it on a list of
things you know i have a
grocery list on my phone basically my
in my notes app
and i will just wait 24 hours and quite
quite awful or 30 hours and quite often
what happened is the next day i crossed
off the list because i'm i'm honest with
myself and i realized like oh that thing
i thought i needed i don't actually need
at all yeah that's a great lead into my
pithy answer which is
when in doubt go without
there's a third option
and it's yeah going without it for a
little bit to see if you really really
need it absolutely and if there's
something that like you're depriving
yourself from and uh it turns out you do
need this this item
i don't think you get bogged down in
this as much as people kind of lead on i
think we get bogged down in it with
things that we actually don't need
that's a good point yeah yeah the things
that are memetic desires oh society told
me i needed that i needed to upgrade my
fashion need to upgrade my car i needed
to upgrade whatever it is now of course
if you run out of printering well first
off you might not be out of printer ink
but the question then is like do i
actually need printer do i need a
printer at all right yeah and ryan and i
have decided we needed a printer for
here because we generally don't have
screens between us we do today because i
had a bunch of articles i needed to read
from but we prefer to do this podcast
without glowing screens in front of us
that create a barrier so it made sense
for us but i don't need a color printer
and we don't need to print nearly as
many things as we used to back in our
corporate days yeah and so can i be more
responsible by just cutting down my use
as well yeah we've got a bunch more to
talk about but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist in fact i got two things for
you today nicodemus the first one is
this is for the listeners at home i have
a free book called 15 ways to write
better it used to be called 11 ways to
write better but we found four new ways
to write it's new and improved updated
yes
it's still free though yeah actually i
should have increased the price from
free times uh well with inflation and
still be free i guess right i guess so
is that how math works yeah i think so
it's just reminds me of textbooks like
you know they always have like the third
edition yeah fourth edition anyway yeah
i'm not going to charge you any more to
to upgrade to this new edition so it's
got the 11 ways to write better plus
four more it's called 15 ways to write
better 15 writing tips the nice thing
about this free ebook you can download
it you can read the whole thing within
15 minutes
so the entire thing and so today you'll
have 15 tips to help you write better if
you download it just go to
howtowritebetter.org that's my writing
website there howtorightbetter.org we'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well and you can download 15 ways to
write better and second ryan we've been
in the studio as you can see this is our
new studio space we've done two other
episodes
in here and i want to thank austin st
john he's a friend of ours who has
helped out with the color grading and
the lighting and making this place just
look stunning on camera
shout out to him because he is a savant
when i see him
um
he came in here with danny this weekend
and we were working with jordan via
facetime
and he comes in here he makes just a few
subtle adjustments and all of a sudden
i'm like yes yeah this
is it this is exactly how we want the
podcast to look you've taken the thing
that i can't describe
vocally
i can't describe it with words and you
described it
with
video and it's right there and it's
beautiful we've created this black abyss
set it's getting back to that minimalist
aesthetic that we started with the the
last podcast studio that we had and so i
just want to say a big thanks to austin
st john for helping us out with uh the
coloring the lighting of the podcast it
looks stunning thanks to you my friend
alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners hi my name is daniel
and i live in charlotte north carolina
in previous podcasts i've heard people
wanting to do more for the environment
but not knowing how they can contribute
i've been using the search engine called
ecosia that's the letter e
c
o s
i
a
dot org ecosia.org this search engine
plants trees with its ad revenue and
while i do agree that advertisements
suck to me it's a small inconvenience to
pay for a great contribution for
searches i'd be doing anyway on the
internet they have already planted over
17 million trees across the globe and
they post monthly video updates on
youtube
hi this is lauren i live in new orleans
i was cleaning out my clothes closet and
dresser this morning and wanted to share
my tip for keeping a minimalist wardrobe
so in my dresser and my closet i have
stacks of
items underwear socks shirts shorts
jeans etc all of my different clothing
items are in stacks
when i do laundry i put the clean items
at the bottom of each stack so the items
that i haven't worn most recently end up
at the top of the stack and i tried to
choose items to wear from the top
each day
that way if i find myself not well not
willing to wear something that's on the
top of the stack
because i don't like it anymore or it
doesn't fit anymore then i know it's
probably time to get rid of it
i also do this with my hanging clothes i
will put the laundred items on the right
side and try to choose items to wear
from the left side so they're also
constantly rotating
consequently i only had a small bag of
items to get rid of during today's purge
because i wear most of the items that i
own
all right y'all before we get to an
outstanding added value segment this
week let's read a sincere comment from
one of our lovely patreon subscribers
sage says i have been listening to the
minimalist podcast since i was 17.
i'm 19 now and i just subscribed to your
private podcast and to that stage i'll
say how dare you freeloading for two
years
unbelievable that's alabama cancel her
patreon subscription immediately that is
so cool that like teenagers listen to
this that's that's awesome man she goes
on to say my mind was in such turmoil
before i found this podcast both because
i was thinking about things that i knew
as a 17 year old i should not have to
think about and because i simply didn't
have anyone around to direct my thoughts
toward your podcast provided me that
outlet you put things that i had been
thinking for years into words
that i had always been afraid to say or
write down there is no doubt in my mind
that the minimalist private podcast has
changed my life wow sage i'm really
honored especially to see
because these are formative years for
you and by the way you're a outstanding
writer for a 19. i mean amazing brava um
now i will say this it's amazing to see
someone go through this journey when
you're young because you're asking some
questions right now i'm so grateful
for your listenership now because many
of the people are listening are in their
20s 30s 40s 50s 60s
and they had to go learn the hard way
right yeah but you're learning through
ryan's and my failures our screw-ups
our inability to stay out of debt
you're learning these things now so you
don't have to get into debt you don't
have to buy things with that you don't
need with money you don't have to
impress people you don't even know yeah
man it's never too late to start and
it's never too early to start either hey
man yeah ryan for our added value this
week oh
my favorite album of the year so far
okay just came out although our our
friend ken yates gave us an advanced
link so i've been listening to this for
about a month now
the album is called cerulean
and it's from ken yates i was going to
play the song constellation prize but he
has this other song on there so i'm
going to call an audible it's called the
best of the broken things oh wow and
since we're talking about the good good
today we've also been talking about a
lot of the bad goods
so to speak
well this song is called the best of the
broken things it's from ken yates from
my favorite album of 2022 so far
cerulean
by the way ryan we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how do
we find clothing companies that use good
quality fabrics and treat their workers
fairly
how do we shop online intentionally
what are eight ways minimalism can help
your finances
and what are seven brands that the
minimalists trust for home furnishings
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown p3 emma the immigrant and the
rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn
if you leave here today with just
one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everybody